[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with the telegraph's chief
political correspondent camilla turner
and the political journalist chaister
aziz thank you both very much for
joining us this evening
so let's see what is on some of those
front pages and the metro leads with
death of our hero they report the death
of jordan gatly a former british soldier
killed while fighting on the front line
in ukraine
rwanda flights may not get off the
ground as a headline on the eye as the
court of appeal is to consider the
government's new migrant policy
while the daily mail story summarizes
the same story with the words new
rwandan flight farce
the financial times reports that the
conservatives have criticized boris
johnson's attempt to rip up the northern
ireland trade deal
whilst the guardian also leads on the
northern ireland agreement carrying a
warning from the confederation of
british industry
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code that you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
well let's get the views of camilla
turner and check easter aziz welcome to
you both and camilla shall we start with
you um the metro uh you guys have gone
with the story about jordan gatley uh as
as the lead story um the metro have
called it death of our hero that was
what his dad called him wasn't it
yes that's correct this is quoting from
the jordan's
family tribute that they paid him in a
facebook post where they announced that
their son jordan just aged 24 um has
been killed fighting um in the front
line in ukraine um his family praised
him they say he's a hero they talk about
how he he loved what he did he went out
to ukraine and they say he wasn't um
only there in his capacity as a soldier
but he was also training ukrainian
troops so they say he'd made a huge
difference doing the thing he loved
doing um now this is of course the
second
british soldier who's been killed
fighting in action um in ukraine um
the ukrainian president has um called on
international fighters to come and join
them in an international legion and help
them defeat president putin's invasion
um but we have the head of the british
army in the uk urging uh people not to
go out and fight and saying that it's
much better to help the ukrainians in
other ways um of course what we have
here is this very tragic situation of a
soldier who's
defied that call from the head of the
british army gone out to fight and sadly
lost his life in doing so
and
she said
do you think that that more should be
done to stop uh british people going out
to fight or do you think that that's not
impossible
well obviously my heart goes out to this
man's family you know to lose your son
at any age but the age of 24 is clearly
very devastating and i hope that his
body can return home and he can have the
funeral that his family want him to have
um as camilla said this is the second
british man to die in ukraine we also
know there are two british nationals who
have been sentenced to death in a
russian court for being involved in
fighting alongside uh ukrainians
alongside moroccan as well so i think
really serious questions need to be
asked about why british men are
traveling to ukraine how are they
traveling to ukraine to go and fight
over there in a war which a lot of
people obviously feel very anguished
about we know there's a great deal of
empathy for ukrainians as they should be
but we still have to ask these questions
what are they doing over there uh the
british army themselves have said they
don't want former british um soldiers
traveling to ukraine uh there's
prospects of anyone going over there who
returns to the country returns to uk
facing potential terrorism charges so i
think it's only right and proper that
there's a degree of scrutiny that is
applied to this story in relation to how
and why this man ended up there and who
else is planning to go out there and
what what is the motivation that is uh
that is leading to this and of course
camilla um people from other countries
have fought in foreign wars since time
immemorial you know we've always had
mercenaries but but camilo are you
concerned that the britons who are going
out there are at greater risk than the
ukrainians especially when you look at
what's happened in the nets can these
two britons getting the death penalty
yes that is very true that these british
people particularly in the case of those
who are awaiting trial in this
russian-backed court and quite possibly
also um face
um face death um
what this presents is an opportunity for
the russians to use it as a propaganda
tool
if they're able to capture these
soldiers um and kind of use it as almost
a show to say to other um
countries other individuals thinking of
going to to join the ukrainian forces um
it really just sends a message to say
well if you do fall into enemy hands
then you
you risk being killed um and you know
potentially tortured or who knows what
might happen so this does um
it does offer a very powerful propaganda
tool to the russians um and i think it
would be in their interest to try and
put off international fighters from
coming to join the ukrainian defence
forces because
it offers of course more people going to
fight but also potentially a morale
boost for the ukrainians to know that
other um fighters in in other countries
are also willing to risk their lives to
come and join them
let's move on to your second story that
you've chosen tonight and this is about
the uh flights to rwanda that the
government wants to put some asylum
seekers on and there has of course been
a legal battle to try and stop this
happening the daily mail
have gone with the headline new rwanda
flight fast
uh and the eye newspaper has gone for
rwanda flights may not get off the
ground so a slightly different tone from
both of them but um
showster
do you think this can be stopped so you
know it does seem that the legal process
is is getting close to the wire given
that tomorrow will just be a day before
these flights are due to leave
well i think firstly we never should
have got into this situation in the
first place i think this policy is
deeply problematic and flawed and i
think it's very likely that you know as
the newspapers are reporting that these
flights won't take off but just to say i
i don't think they should take off i
didn't think needs to be proper scrutiny
legal scrutiny in relation to these
flights in relation to the breaking of
international law and conventions on
refugees rights and also there needs to
be further scrutiny on what will happen
to people when they get to rwanda in
particular i'm very concerned about uh
you know reporting around child refugees
for example there's been reports in the
sunday newspapers that potentially
children could also be deported or
minors and this whole thing it is a
fiasco but not for the reasons that the
daily mail is reporting it's a fiasco
because it basically brings britain into
disrepute in relation to human rights
and refugee conventions and and and the
law and i think it's really shocking
that this is going on at this time and
really what we need to see is empathy we
need to see
the law respected by the government you
know the first story we focused on this
evening is ukraine we know there are
plenty of people fleeing for their lives
uh you know trying to leave ukraine uh
we know that refugees are increasing
around the world and we have to find a
way to create a humane immigration and
refugee uh you know uh
system in this country that is uh
aligned with the law and aligned with
decency and human rights
and camilla the government of course
will argue that these are people who
shouldn't be in this country and that
they have every right to deport them
yes that's exactly right the government
argument hinges on the fact that they
are really wanting to create a deterrent
effect for um
asylum seekers who come to the uk they
call it illegally these are people
coming on small boat crossings across
the channel um in the hope of seeking
asylum in the uk but risking their lives
um
in in doing so and it's interesting what
we've got on tomorrow's front pages both
the mail and the eye concentrate on the
legal challenges that are being mounted
um that could very well ground this
flight that's due to take off on monday
but actually there are two separate
legal challenges that each front page is
talking about so on the one hand um
we've got the mail talking about how
these 31 individuals who are due to be
on this flight tomorrow um each one of
them could potentially have their own
legal challenge um mounted against them
against that flight taking off um so
human rights lawyers acting for every
single one of those
people
um
they're saying the home office are being
hit by a deluge of of legal claims um
which could for each of those
individuals get them off that plane and
then separately we've got the eye
talking about um this overall legal
challenge um which was already which is
against the entire flight taking off
it's a legal challenge against the
policy to send people to rwanda okay all
right we're gonna pause there
just sorry so we're we're just out of
time on this for this section so we're
just gonna pause but we'll be getting
lots more of your thoughts on that in
the 11 30. uh but coming up
conservatives attacked the prime
minister
over his attempt to remove the northern
ireland trade deal
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview uh we've been now the
telegraph's chief political
correspondent camilla turner and the
political journalist shaister aziz
what's happening in northern ireland the
northern ireland protocol and what the
government is going to be trying to do
in
the courts from to debt tomorrow also in
the financial times in the front of the
guardian uh chester what the government
is trying to do tomorrow
do you think it is legal in
international law
no i don't well i don't think it is i
mean we i'm looking at the details on
the front pages legislation hasn't
landed yet but it from the pre-briefing
in the papers it doesn't look
particularly good um it looks like the
uk
is planning to unilaterally override the
northern ireland protocol which
obviously is a breach of international
law and it puts the good friday
agreement in jeopardy and furthermore
it's also um you know this was one of
boris johnson's um pledges on which he
won a mandate in the 2019 election so
this is a very serious situation and it
never should have come to this again
i've already said that once this evening
but it shouldn't have come to this and
um you know for me this really
illustrates again a very cavalier
approach and not only from the prime
minister from this government to
international law and to this uh crisis
because i think that's what it is and
this has been going on for a long long
time it's been rambling on
and on
and now the government is saying you
just need to trust us and it's saying
that potentially it's saying that it
doesn't want to uh publish the full
legal advice that it's received i think
it needs to publish the full legal
advice and i think there needs to be
full transparency and accountability on
this and parliamentary scrutiny needs to
be applied to this as well camilla the
problem for the government is that they
could through doing this alienate europe
further and also simply make the
situation northern ireland worse rather
than better
yes exactly that's completely right this
is in a difficult position for the
government both within northern ireland
but also
how the uk government plays this has a
far broader bearing than just within the
eagle i i just within northern ireland
sorry uh we've got the the financial
times list the kind of coalition of
critics that are ready to to come out
against this legislation once it drops
we've got the government's own um
opposition within its own party for a
start tory mps who who don't like the
sound of what this legislation is going
to contain we've got members of the
lords
eu figures figures in
washington and also figures within
northern ireland so this is a huge
amount of different groups that
potentially um the government's on a
collision course if once it published
its legislation um these these different
groups don't like what they see indeed
uh we've got you got 30 seconds left but
chase so very quickly um also on the
front of the financial times the new
mcdonald's in moscow well it's not
mcdonald's is it it's their russian
alternative has it got your mouth
watering
not really i think this is really a
propaganda tool by the russian state to
say you know you you want to slap
sanctions on us we'll be fine we can
sort out our own burgers
uh and camilla apparently they don't do
much flurries which which is a big minus
in in my in my household
yes that's correct this is going to be
not exactly just mcdonald's as we know
it it's going to be the russian take on
mcdonald's so the menus will be slightly
different different um and as you say if
it doesn't involve mcflurries then it
may be that it drastically declines in
popularity